The sequence diagram and the communication diagram that we've seen aren't
particularly designed to deal with synchronization. UML has a separate diagram,
called an activity diagram, designed for this purpose.
In this diagram it's a variant of a state machine in which.
Multiple states may be simultaneously active. That is have their own threads of
control. This activity diagrams are derived from petri nets.
Petri net diagrams that have been around for many years. In the diagrams trans,
transitions are typically triggered by activity completion.
That is you finished with one state. Rather than by external events. You can
use these diagrams to model workflows, process synchronization, and concurrency.